a violent power struggle between Sudan's
rival military forces has entered its
third week with tens of thousands of
people caught in the crossfire a
faltering ceasefire is due to expire on
Sunday and efforts by foreign powers to
mediate have failed to achieve a lasting
truth so far on Saturday there have been
more airstrikes and artillery shelling
in the capital Khartoum Sudan's Army in
the paramilitary rapid support forces
fought pitched battles around the
presidential Palace well the human cost
has been enormous at least 528 people
have been killed since fighting began on
April the 15th people are running out of
fuel medicine and water thousands of
Sudanese are leaving everything behind
to escape their nation in turmoil more
than 50 000 people have crossed into
neighboring countries Heber Morgan
begins our coverage from Khartoum
a rescue ship carrying nearly 2 000
evacuees from Sudan arrives in Jeddah
welcomed by members of the Saudi Royal
Navy on board are people from 17
countries including Iran
we don't know what should we do thank
you from Saudi Arabia
a good trip would be cheap to Saudi
Arabia and I'm very happy
back in Port Sudan on the Eastern Red
Sea Coast thousands are still waiting to
leave
I was among the people trapped for
nearly seven days in Khartoum with no
food electricity or water the conditions
were very bad but thank God we managed
to leave and come here
around 3 000 yemenis have been stranded
here for six days they say they have no
idea if or when they'll be allowed to
board one of the ferries while countries
scramble to get their Embassy staff and
citizens out intense fighting is taking
place in several parts of Khartoum as
the conflict between the Sudanese Army
and the paramilitary group the rapid
support forces enters its third week
[Music]
both sides say they're making gains and
both blame each other for violating yet
another ceasefire
Heavy Artillery fire could be heard in
umdurman bahri and Khartoum on Thursday
fighter jets belonging to the Sudanese
Army also launched airstrikes on rsf
positions as residents were warned to
stay indoors to avoid getting caught in
the crossfire
the rsf denies this and says it's taking
control of an area south of the capital
the UN Envoy has reiterated calls for a
permanent end to the violence and issued
this warning
Regional countries and the International
Community must say that if the situation
continues even if one side wins the
fight that side would not be accepted
internationally if Assad refuses
negotiations and refuses reconciliation
it will not be accepted internationally
regionally and I think also nationally
in Sudan
Sudan doctors Union has warned the
health system is on the verge of
collapse this hospital is in the city of
Underman
we lack medical staff and Facilities our
shifts have been extended but there are
only one or two doctors to cover two or
three departments in normal
circumstances this wouldn't happen but
now the situation is so difficult
with essential supplies running out
those who can stream out of the country
relieved to be out of immediate danger
but uncertain about when it will be safe
to return Heber Morgan Al Jazeera
Khartoum
well in these are some of the countries
where many people from Sudan are
escaping to Egypt where authorities say
14 000 Sudanese Nationals have entered
in the past week Sudan itself is hosting
more than a million refugees mostly from
South Sudan many of them are now
returning home the UN has registered
about 14 000 returnees and says as many
as 125 000 people are on their way the
UN says at least 20 000 people have
crossed into Chad joining the 400 000
Sudanese refugees who were already there
Ahmed Idris reports from the town of
khoon and Chad on the border with Sudan
this dry riverbed is what separates
Eastern Chad and the town of tendulter
in Western defore over there are homes
and businesses left behind by their
owners because of fear of attacks the
residents woke up one day to find the
military base in town completely
deserted and that has triggered an
exodus of people thousands of them
crossed this dry riverbed into the
village of kofrun in eastern Chad and
they're based there currently thousands
of them under living under harsh
conditions while they can watch across
the dry riverbed at their homes over
there simply because it's not safe for
them to go back to their homes at the
moment now the situation is such that
people are in need of shelter in need of
water in need of food items and they've
been living like that for days until
they arrival a few days ago by U.N
agencies and the world food program
delivered tons of Aid to distribute to
the uh people affected by the crisis and
the migration across the river now
the Walford program budgeted
twenty thousand budgeted for twenty
thousand people are the food they have
in their stores to deal with the needs
of these individuals however from all
indications that number is going to
outgrow the estimation of the world food
program and currently the organization
as well as other donor agencies are
struggling to deal with the influx of
refugees traveling from Sudan into the
eastern part of Chad now 30 kilometers
from where we are is a town of Janina
where that we recently witnessed some
incidents violence incidents who has
soldiers on both sides were killed and
we are told that a lot of people are
trapped in there and they cannot come
this side because of the security
concerns they have rather they are
moving farther Inland into Sudan they
feel safer much much safer going that
way a family a humanitarian organization
family that escaped from Janina and made
it to kofun and then later to adre told
Al Jazeera that they spent days
negotiating their access through a
distance of 500 meters in order to get
to this place and that's the situation
here in eastern at the moment Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera
well as I mentioned large numbers of
people from South Sudan are also trying
to return Al jazeera's Hari matasam it's
some of them in Juba
for migration says there are about 1.5
million people from South Sudan living
in Sudan some of them are refugees
others when they're looking for work
when the fighting started people like
anag Ding and her six children left
Khartoum and came here to South Sudan's
capital Juba a journey that took them
about two days by bus and they're now
staying with family friends who've taken
them in for as long as it takes a
knockding says the journey for her and
the children to get here was traumatic
my children heard gunfire and saw things
they should never see they are still
scared I am happy we got back to South
Sudan savely
foreign
ERS close ties with its neighbor Sudan
remember this country gained
independence from Sudan in 2011 many
people still have friends and family
stuck in Sudan and they're worried about
what's happening over there the same
experience that Sudan went is what I
went through in our crisis in South
Sudan where we have witnessed people
have been killed people have lost lives
people have been displaced and children
and and elderly people have suffered
most so when I saw the fighting in Sudan
it worries me more because I start
wondering the pain that the Sudanese
people are going through salvacare
saltadan's president is leading
mediation efforts as part of the
regional group egad he's trying to get
officials from the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary RSA face-to-face talks here
in the capital Juba government officials
say it's still a work in progress